[Music]
believe it or not I love
people some people oh wait I have
something to show you what oh you didn't
I did don't tell I every schmuck is
getting one I don't even know what they
are I just don't always trust them
thank you
[Music]
Jo they have a bad habit of
leaving Hey Oh My New Haircut keep it in
your pants
perv things though things I
trust things are made to last from place
to place from generation to
[Music]
generation it's why I take stuff and
keep it so the people can stay with me
if that makes me a klepto so be it
because when the people we love are gone
and memories fade what the hell else
keeps them
[Music]
alive
you got to be kidding
[Music]
me